When someone you love has an eating disorder, relationships can start to feel very different. Conversations can become arguments, meal times can become battlegrounds, and sometimes it can feel like the illness is speaking louder than the person you know and love. Today I'm joined by Tiffany, who has personal experience of anorexia as we explore eating disorders recovery compassion and why it's so important to separate the person from the illness. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm joined here today by Tiffany, who is a placement psychology student. Hi, Tiffany. Hi, nice to meet you, Marianne. Thanks for having me on the podcast.
Lovely to be here. And thank you for pitching the podcast to me as well via LinkedIn. So we are getting together today to think about how we can stay compassionate for people that are experiencing eating disorders and also to help think about how we can help them and their families to kind of maybe externalise the eating disorder from the person because that can be so important, can't it? Yeah, definitely. I think that's one of the main things. There's a lot of self-criticism when it comes to eating disorders and I think it's so important that we realise that actually there is an individual behind those behaviours that just really needs that care, support and that love and nurturing.
Please know that if you were to watch the YouTube version, we are not using any images of any low-weight people in our video because that feels really important because I know when we are well, we can look at those images and be really shocked and really sad and moved by distress. But actually those kinds of images for someone who is vulnerable to becoming unwell or is already unwell can really fuel and make things worse, can't they, Tiffany? Yeah, definitely. I think, again, when it comes to eating disorders, it is so easy to become triggered and that can obviously perpetuate the eating disorder. So it's really important that we
kind of spread a positive message around and that's avoiding images, talk of numbers, BMI's, etc. Yeah, which obviously having worked in a service where I've worked with people who do have anorexia or low weight diagnoses, it's really hard because often people live with the medicalised way of treating people. We are asking people to step on the scales and we are trying to think about kind of is this a healthy weight? You know, are you having periods? It's really hard and I think speaking as a clinician, we used to try and have the clinicians that were doing the therapy work for that person, but then a separate staff member who would maybe do the way-ins to try and keep it a little bit separate so that you didn't feel like
you were doing the policing. It's just a really hard area to work in and people would often ask not to see the weight. It's really hard. Yeah, I agree with that. And I think one of the biggest things that I try to do through my work is kind of, I like spread the message that eating disorders are mental health disorders, not physical health disorders. And unfortunately, the way the treatment works, it does kind of again perpetuate that
kind of idea that it's based on physical measures. So it's a physical health disorder, but it's not. The physical symptoms are just a side effect of the mental condition underlying. So yeah, I think it's really important that we realise that how unwell someone is, it isn't determined by BMI, etc. It's the amount of distress around eating, around exercise, around body image. Yeah, and distress is such a powerfully important word because that is often what people just don't see.
there is so much distress. And before we started recording, we were talking about, you know, some of the helpful suggestions that are made for how to, how to kind of, you know, how to make things be different. And people are often like, well, put some butter in your pasta
or put some single cream on your cereal. But that is obviously thought of from a caloric perspective, how can we make sure that whatever this person is eating is going to be as calorie dense as possible. But having to do that is really, really very distressing for the person who, the only sense of control they've got, because this is what this is, isn't it?
This is what eating disorders often are about. It's about control. And this is the variable that they are having to use right now so that they can feel like they've got some semblance of control. Yeah, and again, I think that really gets forgotten about the fact that eating disorders do come down to some form of control and maybe this is control over feelings that have resulted from past traumas and actually it's not about body image it's not all about food and I think that really gets lost sometimes and it's really important that we remember that
that the eating disorder is a way of coping with something that felt unbearable at the time yeah and I think also what's often not understood is that actually people with eating disorders certainly restrictive ones, actually really love food. You know, they'll be really into food and be really into thinking about good quality food and nutrition and, you know, will absolutely wax lyrical with you about their favorite restaurants or their favorite recipes when they are feeling well.
And it's almost like depriving yourself of something as a punishment or a control because that's the thing that's maybe going to hurt most. and that's often overlooked. Yeah, I agree with that. And again, like, I was that typical kind of case of, surely not me that's got an eating disorder. Like, I love food.
I mean, I come from a background where my mom is Japanese and, like, food was such a big part of the Japanese culture. And I loved food. I loved going out trying new recipes, try new meals. And now I'm grateful that's something that I can do again. But like you said, it felt like that was a way of punishing myself. it was something that I loved and it was so important to me and obviously controlling that and like through restriction
that was my way of punishing myself because I feel like I didn't deserve it. Yeah. And it's that non-intentional self-harm. We've got a whole episode on that that's a great list and a great watch if people do want to check that out. So you mentioned there yourself that you have had a history of eating disorders yourself
which has obviously sparked your interest in this into thinking about ways we could do things hopefully better and different. Would you be able to tell us a little bit about your experiences that if that feels comfortable to do so, Tiffany? Yeah, of course. So when I was 16, I began struggling with disordered eating and by the time I was 17, it had kind of turned into a full-blown eating disorder. So I was diagnosed with anorexia. And unfortunately, I just was not able to recover in the community. So I was admitted as an inpatient for about two years. And, and this was during COVID as well.
So it was an extremely challenging time. And I'm grateful to say that I've been recovered for two years now, which is just like if you told me that about five years ago, I would have just laughed really. It didn't feel possible at the time. And I think unfortunately my recovery was quite prolonged and there probably was things that could have been different that would have led to me being fully recovered a lot quicker.
I do feel like, again, unfortunately, I understand the NHS is stretched for funding. It definitely is and there are some amazing clinicians out there. But I think the understanding of eating disorders is not quite there. There were times in treatment settings where maybe there wasn't so much of an understanding of what someone might be going through from that kind of lived experience, And I think when it comes to eating disorders, it is really tricky. And I think there is a lot of tiptoeing. Am I saying the right thing?
Is this unhelpful? And then maybe I just shouldn't say anything. And I think we're so sensitive to the language that people use that unfortunately it can create more conflict and it can kind of keep that eating disorder going. So I think for me I have picked up that maybe there was a bit of a lack of compassion around the language used and the approaches. But again, I do want to highlight that working with eating disorders is quite challenging. I think the treatment's quite brutal and it can feel like you're working against the individual a lot of the time.
But it's really important, again, to remember there is someone behind those behaviours. And we're just humans like everybody else and we deserve that support. Yeah, thank you for sharing a little bit of your story there. So how do we stay compassionate and how do we begin to externalise the difficulties from the person? Yeah, I guess the first thing is like looking at the language used. When we're talking to individuals with eating disorders, I think there can be a lot of kind of frustration and anger. And this can kind of come across as they're angry and frustrated at that individual. So for me, maybe there were times where.
there was conflict between maybe my parents or the staff on the ward and I would internalise it. I'd be like, this is me that's not good enough. This is me that can't do it. I'm a failure. And obviously that like in a compassion that I had, it just became non-existent. And I think already when you have an eating disorder, like self-criticism again is something that you really struggle with. So it's really important that kind of those conversations are directed away from that individual. For me, I didn't necessarily give a name to my eating disorder because this is something a lot of people do to kind of separate the eating disorder from the individual. For me, it was kind of realizing there was this part of me that really needed that care and that support.
And this was what was kind of making me display these behaviours. This is my way of expressing that I needed support and I was struggling. So, yeah, again, it's like really expressing to that person, they're not angry at them. that angry at kind of the behaviours they're presenting. Yeah. And I like the idea that often we will become the adult that we might have needed ourselves as a child. So if we fast track a few years down the line then,
you may ultimately end up working in eating disorders, hopefully as a qualified clinical psychologist, is that fair to say? What adult would you hope, that a 16-year-old Tiffany would meet in a few years' time? Yeah, I guess I just want someone to really kind of validate the pain and the struggle because ultimately that's what is the most distressing and that's what you're there for. It's to kind of work through maybe the trauma that has led up to the development of an eating disorder
and I think connection is so important. it's about being there, listening to that individual. And we don't want solution-based kind of conversations all the time. I think it can be quite difficult. It's kind of like, okay, you get this meal plan. Did you eat this? Did you eat that? Yes, no. Kind of like onto the next thing.
And actually we need to do more of the talking. We need to do more of the getting to know that individual. So I think for me it is about having someone who cares about who you are. other than the eating disorder and really trying to strengthen that part of you. And in doing so, it will kind of weaken that part that needs that care and that support. And because you'll be feeling that connection with others. So ultimately, you can live life how you want to live it. So for me, I feel like in the future, as a clinician,
if I was treating someone like I was when I was 16, that's what I would have needed. I don't need someone to always kind of be in the drive trying to find answers. I just want someone to listen to me. Yeah, and there's usually some element of trauma that has meant that there's been a vulnerability for this, that's been a seed planted in the soil that's germinated when the conditions are right. So we really need to be working with people to help them to process their trauma, to grieve for that and to find hopefully more adaptive ways of of healing themselves and of coping so that so that the what seems like the impossible can happen and you described it to me
as seeming impossible that that you as a 16, 17 year old, 18 year old could ever begin to hold the idea that you might feel comfortable looking at yourself when you were a, what people might describe as a healthy, healthy body weight. But that has happened for you, hasn't it? Yeah. So when I was struggling, I was a lot of the time I was obviously told, like, when you reach a healthy body weight, like your focus turns away from your body and you'll actually feel okay with it and you'll be at peace with it. And you'll be living your life and not thinking about your body all the time.
And I was like, oh, yeah, yeah, whatever. have to say that kind of thing. But actually now obviously coming through the other end, I'm like, yeah, actually you were right kind of thing. It's like I don't think about my body. Definitely not any more than kind of an average person would. I live my life how I want to live it. And my body is like one of the least important things about me.
None of my friends care about how I look, you know. So I think, yeah, it's a real turning point. and I do hate to admit when I'm wrong, but yeah, definitely they were right when they were saying that. And obviously it's really hard when you're in the moment. Like, I mean, obviously going through and coming out the other side, but I still know when I was unwell, you can't think entirely rationally at the time and it does feel impossible. So again, it's just trying not to be self-critical over that. And that's something, I guess, being recovered now, I look back and I'm like, oh, if I just did that,
if I just did that, but it's important again to remain compassionate to yourself. Yeah. Would you say, looking back, would you say it's a little bit like OCD that you kind of need to almost stay using the approaches forever because OCD will often look for a vulnerability to kind of creep back in again if you've had it? Would you say that kind of eating disorders are similar? Or once you're recovered, is it just, are you kind of one and done, would you say? Yeah, I think it's a difficult one. I do think it can vary from person to person, but I think for me, I don't have like eating disorder thoughts as such, but there is always in the back of my head kind of like I don't want to ever slip back into it. Like I think it's being more cautious than maybe the average person when it comes to food. I think I'm definitely more sensitive to other people's cues as well. So kind of like if I see someone who's maybe, you know, not eaten a certain meal at the time that maybe everybody else is meeting, eating.
And then I'm kind of thinking like, oh, what's going on there? So it might not even necessarily be about myself, but I think just having that awareness. And again, for me, it's kind of like I'm always making sure that I've eaten enough. And I think it's just kind of like, it's not actively having thoughts, but it's like, I don't ever want to go back there. So it's just being more aware about that. I know social media can be full of fitness stuff and exercise stuff. at the moment too, can't it?
Yeah, I think with exercise as well, it took me a long time to get back into exercise because I had such kind of like toxic relationship with it. And I think when I first started going back, I was very hypervigilant about it. I was thinking, am I doing this for the right reasons? So I think, again, it is kind of like a stepped process and it's just always being aware. And of course, like being a young woman in her 20s, like I'm still going to compare myself to other people and how other people look. But it's just about kind of like comparing yourself
but then not acting on any thoughts that come up and realising that actually these are normal thoughts. Like unfortunately we are kind of in a society where we're made to compare each other's bodies and it's just about being able to focus on like your values and who you are as a person and really recognising that the body isn't the most important thing about us because it definitely isn't.
Yeah. And it's that idea that, yes, we may be human. Yes, we may both be female, but they might be the only things we have in common. You know, there are people out there in the world who are studying to be medics. There are people out there who are studying astrophysics. There are people who are studying to be yoga teachers. There are people who are studying to be psychologists. how can we possibly begin to compare all of those people just because they happen to be male, just because they happen to be female. It's like comparing an apple and a banana.
The two things are not the same. Yeah, exactly. And I think that's a massive thing for me. Like comparison was definitely the fief of joy for me. In fact, it was like the fief of just life in general. I mean, I compared myself to my sister a lot when I was growing, up and I think this contributed again to kind of some of the behaviours that I then developed. So, for example, she's very academically talented. She does work very hard and I'm obviously very,
very proud of her. And she is now studying at Cambridge. She's doing aerospace engineering. And I think when she got into Cambridge, I actually cried. As much as I was happy for her, I just obviously that comparison had crept in. And there is no hard feelings between us. we are close but obviously like I kind of latched on to that but then now I kind of look at it and I'm like but I don't want to do aerospace engineering at Cambridge so why am I getting so worked up over this kind of thing so I think it's really about focusing on your values and realizing like what you want to do and not doing things just because other people are doing it if everybody was the same it would be so boring like we're different for a reason and I think it's really important to
remember that. Yeah. You do the aerospace engineering in Cambridge and I'll meet you for shopping and an afternoon tea there. Exactly. And maybe punting on the river and that, that will be lovely. But I don't want to do the aerospace engineering. Exactly. Because we are different people and those differences should be celebrated and nor does she want to pursue a psychology career and that has to be okay. No, exactly. Yeah. Like she hates writing essays and I hate doing maths all the time. So it is like completely different. Yeah, absolutely. I'm aware there's a book called I had a black dog that I often used to use in adult mental health services. And that is the idea of externalisation. That is the idea that I think Winston and Churchill first kind of started talking about.
The idea that you could separate low mood and depression from the person and talk about it to something different. So throughout the book, this black dog kind of gets carted around different areas of the areas of this person's life, it shows up in their relationships, it shows up in their sleep, it shows up with the way they're thinking about themselves. And this can be sometimes a helpful way of helping the family surrounding the person that's experiencing an eating disorder, but also the person themselves to begin to get a little bit of leverage to separate themselves from the presentation. So maybe not a black dog, but we've used all the sorts of different things. People might call it like an orc from Lord of the Rings. They might be like
the dark thing or, you know, the spiky thoughts or the, you know, the poison or they, it's important that they would kind of name this themselves or that you help them to work through how it feels or how it sounds. What's your kind of stance on externalising eating disorders, Tiffany? Yeah, of course I think it's really important. And I think, again, it differs for everybody's So some people, for example, found it helpful to give it a name, and then it was almost like another identity in a sense. For me, like I said, it wasn't necessarily given it a name, but identifying it as this part of me that needed that support and that care.
And that was preventing me from living life in line with my values. So I think that's how I looked at it. And I think, again, it's really important that other people are really aware of maybe the language they're using or how they're approaching that individual and really realizing that this, the eating disorder is kind of like masking that person behind it
and it's really about breaking down that wall and looking beyond it. And yeah, I think it's true, like it does feel like a constant weight. Like it goes with you everywhere. It obviously goes with you to the dining table, but then it goes with you to when you sleep, when you're having social interactions.
And it is like this, heavy weight and for me it kind of felt like this like just dark mass i guess um that was constantly like spinning around in my head and i think it becomes so easy to think it is you and that is who you are but actually it's not um that's not you it's just at the moment it's bigger than the part that allows you to live life in line with how you want to yeah and i think it's even more complicated because for the family it feels like it's an enemy, like a bad thing. Doesn't always feel like that to the person that's got, you know, the difficulties going on themselves. Yeah, exactly.
I think I spent so much of my time recovering or even before I was actively recovering, just thinking this is my fault, I chose this. Like I don't deserve recovery. Again, that really self-critical voice coming in. And I think that's where it's so important for that externalisation. It's realising, no, you did not choose this. No one would choose to have an eating disorder. I fail to believe that.
And that we just ended up here. Like, we're all humans. We didn't choose to be here either. We just ended up here. And it's about really just working with that individual in helping them to kind of, I guess, live life. live life in line with how they want to. Yeah, absolutely. Just before we finish,
I'm reminded of a really lovely episode that I did with a very inspiring trainee psychologist called Jacob, and he's care experienced. And he really does great work around talking about the importance of knowing the impact of being care experienced and also how it can be really validating and can really help rapport and for everybody to do a bit of a deep exhale, to have people that are care experienced in services supporting young people
who are living in care or having care experiences as they grow. Would you say it's important to do a little bit of self-disclosure if someone is working in eating disorders and has had that experience themselves? It's always difficult as a clinician, isn't it? but what's your opinion? Personally, I think lived experience is so important in these settings. And I think for me, like, I would have wanted more of that when I was going through treatment. And I understand that obviously there are kind of like boundaries that are set.
But I personally don't see the harm in someone disclosing lived experience if they're working as a clinician. Obviously, this is up to them to disclose. and I guess it's down to that individual to be really bounderied with what they share or kind of like how much they can support someone. But I think it is just so helpful. Like you said, it just, that individual understands what it's like to have lived it. And I think sometimes it can feel like you're being treated out of a textbook. And I'm not saying that clinicians without lived experience aren't as good.
That's definitely not true. But again, I just see so much value in kind of, of having that shared experience. But it is tricky and I think it will really vary from person to person. I know as a clinician in the future I would want to share my experience and my story. Yeah, and I obviously spend a lot of time supporting aspiring psychologist and I'm a curious scientist practitioner. I don't know whether there's potentially room. We've spent a lot of time talking about service user involvement and kind of service user led research. But for me, feels like if this isn't already happening in services for people with eating disorders,
that it would be really great to have even a group that runs once a week or once every few weeks where people who have been through this and have obviously been kind of trained and guided by the clinicians in the service but are there to be with people so that they can show them what recovery might look like and so that you really are singing from that hymn sheet. And when I've I've worked with people with eating disorders, they haven't been able to find anybody who actively talks about being recovered so they can see what that looks like. There's lots and lots of narratives around people who are still struggling, but not so much around. Look how glorious life can be when you are recovered.
Yeah, and I think, unfortunately, there is a little bit of kind of like catching up to do with that. I think a lot of services are starting to implement. men expert by experience talks and maybe groups that have involvement of like lived experience perspectives. This is something I have started doing. But I do think it's something that should be kind of compulsory in all services, to be honest. I think it is key to the treatment and in recovery to have that kind of opportunity to talk to someone who's been through it and just to feel empowered really in their recovery. And I think, like, for me, that is the most important work that I do is, like, the expert by experience talks and being able to kind of sit with someone.
They're like, you just, you get me. That's what I'm going through. Like, I've never heard anyone, like, make me feel so understood before. And it is because, obviously, you are both going through that specific thing. it's difficult because obviously again if you're doing lived experience work you have to be in that position where you're you aren't going to get triggered and it is really really important that you put yourself first so it took me a while to get into the work that I do and like the lived experience research that I do as well but just like hearing how helpful it is to all the individuals that I speak with I just really hope it is something that becomes compulsory in all services yeah and like you said I'd echo that you absolutely don't know need to have had an eating disorder yourself to be a really effective clinician in that service but I think we can all learn so much from people who have had first-hand experience of this. Let's think more about where we can learn about you and your work. Where can people
check out your TEDx for example? Yes, so I did a TEDx talk last year, which I still can't quite believe that actually did, given someone that hated public speaking literally like a year ago. So it is on YouTube. I guess it will be linked below as well. I also am developing a website at the moment where you'll be able to access my lived experience resources that I've created. I found that obviously I was going to different services
and contributing these resources, but obviously being a full-time student, I'm working. I wasn't able to kind of reach lots of individuals. So I'm like, if I've got these resources, I might as well put them out there. So there'll be free downloadable. resources such as posters and workbooks, which will be uploaded online. So the website's called the recovery wave. And I guess that really reflects how recovery is up and down, but ultimately it
does lead to a beautiful thing. And also I'll be uploading resources for students, for trainee clinicians, for professionals working in eating disorders. And their training resources kind of covering a whole range of different topics as well. Great. Thank you. And what's your username on LinkedIn in case anyone wants to follow you there? Yeah, so my LinkedIn is Tiffany Luxford. And Luxford is L-U-X-F-O-R-D. Yeah, that's correct. Amazing. Thank you so much for sharing your knowledge
and your experience with us so warmly and so generously. I hope this does help people. And if people have found this helpful, please do drop us a comment. please do follow us on socials, tag us on socials because it's always really lovely knowing when this resonates. Thank you again for your time, Tiffany. Thank you so much. I really appreciate it.
It's always a pleasure to kind of talk about my experience and have the opportunity to kind of get the word out there really. Thank you so much for your time and for pitching to me too. Thank you. Bye. Thank you so much for watching or listening to this stage and for Tiffany's time in speaking with us. We were really careful about how we phrased things
and how we wanted to put things across. So we hope this has not been a triggering episode for you. Of course, sometimes realisations and breakthroughs happen and you think actually now is the time for me to access some treatment, support or advice. Please do check out the NHS guidance and advice for people that are experiencing eating disorders. There's also beat eating disorders.
and do consider contacting Shout or the Samaritans for advice or support too. It's also very important to be supported and understood and validated if you love someone who is experiencing an eating disorder. So please do take a look at the resources on those websites that are there specifically for you too. I enjoy connecting with Gemma Oten, who is over on LinkedIn and also has her own. charity, which was born of her own struggles with eating disorders. So do check out the seed eating disorders service too. Thank you so much for being here. If you like the idea of externalisation and you'd like to learn more about it, it's a little technique borrowed from
narrative therapy. And you can check out the recent episode I did with a lovely trio of psychologists all looking into older adult work and narrative therapy. Pete. There's so much to learn there. Hope that you will love it if you do check it out. And if you do have any comments about that episode or this episode or any of my content, if you're loving it, I really like it. When you tag me, when you share it on socials, when you tell your friends, your family. So please do come and connect with me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If like Tiffany, you're an aspiring psychologist, I think you'd really enjoy the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term.
It's your way of gaining insight, experiences and confidence to help you springboard to the next step of your psychology career. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.